avec Julien chedida bonjour Julien
bonjour Philomène nous commençons par
l'Italie les élections législatives
anticipées ce dimanche prochain et la
perspective d'une victoire de l'extrême
droite et de plus en plus net
effectivement on va faire un petit tour
d'horizon de la presse italienne on va
commencer avec libéraux du journal
conservateur qui titres tout simplement
cette fois et bien c'est la bonne avec
en une les leaders de la droite
italienne réunis derrière celle qui
pourrait être la prochaine femme à
diriger le pays elle s'appelle Georgia
Meloni elle est à la tête de Fratelli
d'Italia un parti d'extrême droite tous
les sondages donnent cette coalition
largement tête du scrutin qui aurait le
dimanche et qui inquiète surtout une
frange de l'électorat et pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle suscite l'inquiétude et bien
parce que Georgia Meloni est loin d'être
une novice c'est une étoile montante de
la politique italienne elle a été la
plus jeune ministre sous silure
Berlusconi et il faut mettre à son actif
qu'elle n'a jamais trahi ses idéaux si
on peut dire le la République à nous le
rappelle est le titre d'ailleurs
l'Italie est à nous avec un programme
assez conservateur voire même très
conservateur priorité donnée aux
Italiens positions extrêmement
conservatrice sur les questions
sociétales notamment sur les fichiers
l'immigration limitée à son maximum et
elle ne cache pas non plus son
admiration pour un certain Benito
Mussolini la presse de gauche est très
critique avec envers cette femme
évidemment la standpa se moque même du
fait que lors d'un grand meeting à Rome
récemment la candidate et ses alliés
n'est pas réussi à ressembler les foules
sur la Piazza del Popolo c'est une des
plus grandes places de Rome l'équivalent
un peu de notre place de la Concorde ici
à Paris et bien c'était pas grave parce
que la candidate est bien depuis le
début de la campagne a fait une
ascension qu'on peut dire fulgurante
nous rappelle la Stampa éclipsant même
les anciens ténors de la droite
italienne et les électeurs pourraient
bien être derrière elle au rendez-vous
ce dimanche mais comment est-ce que ce
scooter italien est-il vu par la presse
en France et bien assez mitigé on va
dire parce que il y a des jours je vous
rappelle en Suède c'était l'extrême
droite qui arrivait au pouvoir et
Libération voit d'un mauvais œil ce même
scénario se répétait de l'autre côté des
Alpes on apprend aussi dans le quotidien
de gauche que le président
démissionnaire du Conseil italien Mario
Draghi était le meilleur allié européen
d'Emmanuel Macron et à l'Elysée et bien
il y a une crainte de revivre les années
compliquées lorsque la droite populiste
de Matteo Salvini était au pouvoir en
2018 et avait créé un incident
diplomatique avec la France pour
comprendre politiquement où se place
Georgia Meloni l'opinion nous dit avec
nous le dit avec ce dessin très
explicite pour les idées je suis plutôt
Éric Zemmour et pour Marine Le Pen je
suis plutôt Marine Le Pen pour en ce qui
concerne les scores voilà pour les
comparaisons mais surtout finalement
n'allez pas dire que Marine Le Pen et
Georgia Meloni sont les mêmes pas du
tout c'est pas du tout pareil nous
explique le monde leur relation sont
même au point mort si l'Italia d'admirer
son homologue française c'était avant en
2015 depuis chacune à tracer sa route
historiquement le rassemblement national
de Marine Le Pen est plus proche de la
Ligue du Nord de Matteo Salvini et pour
Georgia melon c'est si elle s'est alliée
à ce dernier c'est seulement par
pragmatisme et il y a surtout la
question russe qui est au centre des
débats
l'italienne ne supporte pas clairement
je cite le monde Vladimir Poutine alors
que on sait très bien que Marine Le Pen
n'a jamais caché son admiration pour le
mettre du Kremlin au moins jusqu'à ce
que la guerre en Ukraine ne débute et
justement en parlant Vladimir Poutine ça
décision Julien de mobiliser une partie
de sa population pour aller sur le foin
Ukraine passe mal en Russie oui on l'a
vu hier avec ses dépays encore
aujourd'hui on l'a vu avec ses départs
massif de russe qui tend le pays pour
tous les pays proches ou les avions
russes peuvent encore se rendre
libération titre c'est sauf qu'il peut
et nous raconte dans ces pages la peur
de ces russes d'aller combattre en
Ukraine avec ce témoignage glaçant d'un
d'un russe qui témoigne sous anonymat
personne n'a envie de mourir pour le don
de basse mais ce qui est intéressant
Philomé bien ce sont les analyses que
fait la presse étrangère de cet exode de
si on peut dire forcée avec d'abord le
New York Times qui voilà un sérieux
revers pour Vladimir Poutine le
processus n'est pas aussi solide qu'on
aurait pu le croire et qui écrit le
quotidien allusion au fait que la
population la population pardon nous
soutiendrait pas autant la guerre en
Ukraine que voudrait nous le faire
croire la propagande russe le spectateur
qui est un hebdomadaire britannique lui
affiche en une un Vladimir Poutine
acculé seul et bien c'est justement ça
qui inquiète la presse internationale
personne ne sait comment réagirait le
dirigeant russe en cas de nouvelle échec
de l'armée russe en Ukraine avec regardé
dans les mains du petit Vladimir Poutine
un petit bouton qui n'est autre que
cette fameuse menace de l'arme nucléaire
qu'il a encore brandi lors de son
discours appelant à la mobilisation
partielle de sa population on change de
sujet avec un tournoi historique et ça
se passe Julien en Irlande du Nord avec
ce recensement tout récent qui va
peut-être modifier la carte politique de
ce petit État du Royaume-Uni
effectivement pour la première fois
depuis un siècle depuis quasiment la
création du pays et bien la population
d'Irlande du Nord comprend plus de
catholiques que de protestants alien
siècle s'étend environ deux tiers de
protestants sortir de catholiques
l'Irlande du Nord a changé écrit la
Irish Times c'est même un coup porté aux
unionistes protestants fidèles à la
Couronne britannique face aux
républicain catholiques évidemment cela
ne va pas remettre en question les
accords de paix du vendredi 5 avaient
été signé en 1998 et qui avait mis fin
je le rappelle à plus de 30 ans de
guerre civiles mais avec un tel résultat
et bien la question d'une potentielle
réunification de toutes les guirlandes
se pose à nouveau en tout cas pour the
Irish news depuis le brexit 20% des Nord
Irlandais ont un passeport irlandais
jusqu'à présent c'était surtout pour
garder une citoyenneté et des droits
européens mais à Dublin certaines voies
appellent un rassemblement plus
important avec le voisin Nord irlandais
de l'autre qu'au quotidien je veux dire
joue la carte de la prudence parce qu'on
sait que cette question est extrêmement
sensible au Royaume-Uni oui pas de
triomphalisme nous dit des Irish
independante s'il doit y avoir
transformation il faut qu'elle soit
consentie écris le quotidien car à
l'époque de la loi du plus fort et
désormais révolu ne surtout pas répéter
les erreurs du passé d'un conflit dont
les stigmates sont encore présents dans
la population Nord irlandaise
aujourd'hui avant de nous quitter vous
avez voulu évoquer ce geste écologique
que vous mettez un truc guillemets en
place la ville de Paris oui en tout cas
c'est une tentative appelons-le
extinction des feux à Paris puisque la
Tour Eiffel va s'éteindre ce soir pour
des raisons d'économie d'énergie alors
pas de panique la Tour Eiffel ne va pas
s'éteindre au totalment elle s'intira
jusqu'à
23h45 au lieu d'une heure du matin
objectif nous dit Le Parisien réduire la
facture d'économie de d'électricité
pardon d'au moins 10%, mais les
touristes seront-ils encore en
rendez-vous il y a toujours des
mécontents les commerçants du quartier
de la Tour Eiffel ont peur que les
touristes ne soient plus là lorsque la
terre Eiffel sera éteinte mais il faudra
s'y faire la ville de Paris s'est
engagée à réduire ses consommations
entre économie et écologie bien il faut
parfois choisir merci beaucoup Julien
chedidas c'était la revue de presse